the lowest moment of gosh there's been
so many I feel bad saying that because I
try to be again you know I have to
constantly like okay be positive be
positive um I think you're being real I
think a lot of you yeah um and the
lowest moment I guess um gosh that is a
good question and I'm trying to give you
like one in particular I guess one in
one in particular was um I guess let's
just go now give me a couple
circumstances is this um this movie
mallet chance now I got flown there and
everything like that and you know I was
there a couple days and one of the
people I was rooming with was this guy
from jackass so this guy you know I'm
very wide open and this guy he they fly
men in New Orleans and they go out
partying that night and I just want to
stay in my hotel room just cuz I you
know I had my two lines I just didn't
want to it up so so I'm studying by
two lines and this is a true story and
so he came back around 1am they told me
out they're gonna pick me up like seven
and this got this guy he just left he
just uh flowback didn't tell the
production you know I didn't you know
they came they came to pick me up and
they said okay where's ours I'm like oh
I don't know and I guess it was a very
and then the movie after that didn't get
done I guess it was a low low type of
feeling and um i guess it's funny now I
look back but it's like you you know I I
just felt like oh you know I felt like I
had a break and then this is going to
happen you know and I guess another low
feeling which you know I booked this
show criminal minds and I have one line
which the reading everything like that
everything I was so excited and
I get a call and they said your parts
bin right now it was the most you know
flush hating type of you know you feel
like because I don't get the actual
auditions for TV and I try and I try and
I don't get one but at the same time you
know he called me a couple weeks later I
ended up booking a bigger role in the
show which is good but it's I guess it's
just that feeling Karen of like you it's
like you study and study and your work
in your work and you don't get results
and to be honest with you that happens a
lot you just don't get results and it's
it sometimes it's a fuss rating way to
live but um you just have to stay
positive I guess so it's been a lot of
low moments bola what high moments
you